all right let's get into this week's
mailbag info davidpakman.com is the
place to email if you have something to
say sometimes we'll take a youtube
comment or a tweet reply or a facebook
message or whatever starting today in
fact indeed with a facebook message from
gianni who said you look like a soy jack
in real life effing loser now this was a
new one i i recently asked on my twitter
what does it mean to be cuck-pilled i
not a term i'd heard before last week
and it was unclear what it meant i also
didn't know what a soy jack is so i
looked this one up this one apparently
is a meme
which is often used in online discourse
where you post a soy jack which i guess
is an image um and the idea is when you
post it you're saying the person you're
arguing online with is a betta soy boy
uh
so that's that and apparently i am a soy
jack in real life maybe not on the
internet but in real life i am a soy
jack so very very important messaging
there
brandon wrote in about a potential biden
pardon of trump
and brandon says
david long time listener first time
question wondering if you could unpack
the hypothetical scenario of biden
pardoning trump in an effort to bring
the country together to avoid the
inevitable political and cultural
turmoil of such a process thank you for
your level-headed perspective you know i
don't think it's completely out of the
realm of possibility that if the next
few months or the next year for trump go
in a particular way and i would call it
going south for lack of a better term
i actually don't think it's completely
impossible
that biden would consider such a pardon
again to unite the country sort of in
the way that it happened with nixon
but my hope is that he wouldn't do that
because at some point we have to be
if no one is above the law
it means not only that anybody can be
charged but it has to mean that people
actually have to have consequences for
the things that they do if they are
found guilty of doing those things so i
do think brandon's instinct is right
that biden does seem like the type of
guy
who would go above partisanship
and in certain scenarios might say i i'm
going to pardon donald trump we're
thinking many steps ahead
but i hope that it doesn't happen
because i do think that we really need
to put our money where our mouths are
when it comes to individuals not being
above the law and that means when
there's a consequence you don't get out
of it because you used to be the
president
greg wrote in about this deep state
assassination plot theory we've heard
from
right wingers like
steve bannon
and
rudy giuliani and others over the last
few weeks that the mar-a-lago raid might
be the first step by the deep state to
eventually assassinate donald trump and
it sounds crazy greg says here's my
theory
regarding the deep state assassination
attempt you're always saying that when
the right is accusing
they're usually the ones guilty i
believe they're floating it out there
for one of their own to assassinate
trump so that they can make a martyr out
of him in hopes to push their agenda
further and also make the democrats look
terrible what are your thoughts thanks
love the show right that's an
interesting idea and in fact there could
be two layers
let's just think about motive just
because it's fun even if we don't think
this is really what's going on
if you are a republican and you're
worried that trump is really terrible
for your movement
you could say hey you know what's
perfect
let's get trump killed
because then one we get him out of the
way
and two
we can run on the left killed him and
it'll just be great for us we can have a
non-trump candidate energized by this
alleged assassination of trump by the
deep state or by the left or whatever
certainly a beautiful beautiful uh idea
i don't think that that is what they are
planning
in this particular case but if you
disagree certainly let me know because
it's an interesting one keith also wrote
to me about the trump assassination
and trump and keith says david what
group has brought up assassination
the far right
trump is cooked he's going to be a bad
package as investigations continue
it is not the democrats or some nutty
deep state
it will be the republicans getting
traction and political support as
republicans take him out the republican
leadership are done with him and want to
take control of their party again make
trump a martyr cause a total political
uproar
bannon will take him out well listen if
the right wants to kill trump i don't
think it's going to be bannon
uh
but
keith with a similar idea there for sure
and again i get the motive truly the
motive actually does make a lot of sense
but um i don't actually think that
that's what's going on
austin has sort of gotten to the end of
his rope
austin wrote in and says if herschel
walker wins
i'm out
david sir this is a roy well okay the
email says it's austin but then says
it's roy this is roy from south jersey
as we know herschel walker is a disgrace
a joke and cannot speak
but this crossed the line
his ex-wife aired a commercial where she
described him choking beating and
pointing a gun at her on multiple
occasions walker's response
went quote when they attacking me that
means they are scared of me they know
i'm going to be the one to win that seat
because they got to come out and try to
attack me continue to bring up things
that is really helping me i wanted them
i'm glad they brought up the attack with
my ex-wife this is uh done a long time
ago it was done to help people because
that uh commercial there only tells
people i'm gonna continue to be a
warrior
i'm going to continue to fight for
mental health
him beating his wife was done to help
other people
if he wins i'm moving i don't know where
but i cannot live in a country where one
of 100 senators is this mentally
challenged and or evil
i don't know that i would use all the
exact same words that austin roy
is using here
but
there is a certain despondency
that i completely identify with
if this guy can win despite being unable
to even put together a coherent sentence
over the
intelligent and well-versed and
politically knowledgeable raphael
warnock
it would be such a humiliation for
everything we know
of our country
and listen i'm not threatening to move
but it would be really really bad
brian wrote in about beau hines and says
david did you see the bo hines interview
he's a trump endorsed former college
football player that's running for
congress in north carolina he thinks
when people are calling the u.s a banana
republic they're referring to the
clothing store
the republican party is
indistinguishable from an snl skit or an
onion article brian from minnesota i did
see that it's a wild clip i don't have
it pulled up here
but you can easily find it if you google
bohein's banana republic
he talks about
like it when he mentions oh they're
calling us a banana republic he talks
about the manager of a banana republic
store like he completely doesn't get the
banana republic is a pejorative for
countries
whose you know the the idea is that
they've gotten advanced enough
to produce bananas
and it's a pejorative and it's not a
term that i tend to use quite frankly
uh keith wrote in and says conservatives
aren't a fraction of the population
especially when considering that
demographics show that as of 2021
23 of americans age 18 to 29 are
considered conservative compared to 45
percent of american 65 plus
likewise 34 of americans 18 to 29 are
liberal compared to 21 of american 65
plus compare the conservative and
liberal stats and that would be 68
demographic majority compared to a 55
liberal minority hardly a fraction of
the population of conservatives as you
falsely stated it also wasn't a fraction
of the population that got trump elected
into office a gallup poll as recently as
2019 showed conservatives outnumbered
liberals 25 states and highly in 19
states based on all of that you have no
idea what you're talking about so this
no keith i'm sorry you have no idea what
i'm talking about so there's two things
here and all of this word salad doesn't
address it number one
when you talk to people
about their views on issues you quickly
realize that the country is as left as
it has been since polling has existed
you ask about
should the government provide a basic
level of health care to everybody even
if they can't pay okay you look at the
answers on that you ask people should
the government tax the very rich in
order to help the very poor have a basic
standard of living you ask about whether
abortion should be legal in most cases
you ask about gay marriage
you ask about is climate change real
when you talk to people about issues you
find an electorate that is as left as it
has been in the modern political era
number two
it really is a minority that got trump
elected into office only about half the
country votes
and less
than half of those who voted
voted for trump right hillary got more
votes and biden got more votes okay
so it is literally a minority of the
country that got trump elected
so
the polls you're talking about are how
do people self-identify i know tons of
people that say i'm a conservative and
then i ask them their views on issues
and they're liberal on every issue so
it is you that is confused keith and i
would encourage you to you know maybe
read up a little bit
jasic wrote in
and says david sir you've already
addressed several times the
conservatives response to all criticism
of hershel walker's inability to
vocalize his thoughts on any subject but
i can't recall you emphasizing the
context he's running for senate which
requires intellectual capacity the
definition of discrimination is unjust
or prejudicial treatment so it is not
discriminatory to expect the person
making the most consequential decisions
for the entire country to make some
sense yeah that's a fair point
often when i and others criticize
herschel walker for being unable to
express his political positions on any
issue for being unable to speak
coherently for just mumbling word salads
that don't make any sense some of the
reaction will be oh you know you're
you're discriminating against people who
maybe lack education or lack cognitive
capacity or have mental illness or have
chronic traumatic encephalopathy or
whatever
no but what i'm saying is it we have a
hundred senators
and they should be able to think clearly
and express themselves coherently and so
walker doesn't meet the requirements and
of course the
in a literal sense the requirements are
to be a citizen and to be the right age
but and to live in the state in which
you're running
what we would all as a collective
society i think agree on is we should
have smart people who can understand
issues and explain themselves and speak
um
it is not discriminatory in the sense
that he doesn't meet those fundamental
basics and i think jasic is completely
correct um paul wrote in about electric
cars
and he does not like my recent defenses
of electric cars saying cars are the
most dangerous
inefficient
expensive and environmentally and
socially harmful means of transportation
available
electric cars reduce one of those
problems carbon emissions although with
some offsetting costs in terms of mining
if you really want to address the
climate disaster you need to focus on a
host of reforms which will reduce or
eliminate our dependency on cars as our
primary means of transportation listen
i'm right there with you there is no
greater advocate than me for better
public transit this means both within
and between cities
our
national rail is a complete and total
joke
we um in many cities public transit is a
joke i would much rather a future
in which vehicles are
sort of on demand and driverless so that
listen for most of us our cars sit in a
driveway
on the street or in a garage
90 percent of the time or more of the
day right most people the you most
people aren't driving two and a half
hours a day which is like 10 of the day
um so my preference would be
dramatically reduce the number of
vehicles have an on-demand system
where when you actually need a vehicle
it shows up gets you where you need to
go and then brings other people around
the the reforms we need are dramatic
dramatic and yes obviously just public
transit is great the reality in the
united states when there are so many
suburban and rural areas is it seems
more likely to me that on-demand
autonomous electric vehicles
are going to be
a better fit for parts of the country
than like bus high-capacity buses where
you just don't have the number of people
needing these particular uh routes
uh to justify it financially in much of
the country that is the perfect solution
so listen i'm with paul uh but when it
comes to electric vehicles versus
internal combustion engines i'm on the
side of electric vehicles info
davidpakman.com questions comments
whatever
let me know info davidpakman.com and of
course make sure that you are signed up
at join pacman.com so that you get
instant access to the bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad hard to make
a better case for the bonus show than
that
join pacman.com we will see you then oh
today
on the bonus show i will tell the story
of my first visit to a starbucks in 20
years it happened earlier this week how
did it happen
and what happened i will tell you